when I was working as a registered nurse
I was also traveling to many different
parts of the world and that's where I
realized that these hospitals don't have
any medical supplies to take care of
patients and that's really when I said
to myself I am going to figure this
problem out and that's what I've done my
name is Elizabeth McClellan and I'm the
president and founder of partners for
world health our healthcare system is
extremely complicated
there are many federal rules and
regulations in our country and as a
result of that all health care centers
have to discard medical supplies because
they may have been in a patient's room
these are not used medical supplies they
are clean they're unopened and could be
used in the developing world I started
collecting medical supplies in 2007 and
because there was no place to store them
in healthcare facilities I started to
take them home my seller filled up from
the floor to the ceiling and it
overflowed into the downstairs bathroom
until there was just a little path that
I could follow and then eventually in
September of 2009 I put my money in to
rent the first warehouse and there are
so many people that have joined with us
on this to keep it going so it has a
life of its own now which is pretty
exciting
we load the containers with fifteen to
eighteen thousand pounds of discarded
medical supplies we collect these
discarded supplies now from all over the
state of Maine New Hampshire Vermont and
fifteen hospitals of Massachusetts and
we bring them up here to our
distribution warehouse where we sort
through all of these supplies we package
them check expiration days and we ship
the container loads over to different
countries in Asia and Africa to the
Middle East all over India and Pakistan
and Sri Lanka etc after the hurricane
were in Puerto Rico we identified that
there was huge meat down there and so we
are shipping the fourth container of
medical supplies to be distributed in
Puerto Rico
I'm dr. Hasan Salva la from the
Department of pediatric of Puerto Rico
Chadron hasta after maria will lost a
lot of supplies that the scope syringes
blood pressure monitors is very
important to us to replace those to know
people like Elizabeth and the crew that
just loaded that truck and that
container to bring in here is very
important for us those supplies will be
used to evaluate pediatric patients here
in our hostel and even in our community
health centers
we have a model that works so there's a
way to do this if I can collect one bag
of medical supplies now look what's
happened and so it's important that we
recognize that there are so many people
in our world that would benefit from
these discarded medical supplies so
that's why I'm doing this because it's
very important to me that we try to
reach out and be committed to something
greater than our own self-interest and
make a difference in our world
[Music]
you